so what have we done here we have taken
advantage of a very basic property of
this partial sum that you're going up by
a common difference every time and we've
taken advantage of it by doing looking
at the same series and looking at it
backwards okay now here's what I'd like
you to try and do this is a specific ap
this is a specific arithmetic
progression right but I would like to
come up with an idea that works with
every arithmetic progression
okay now this logic that I walked you
through you see this this doubling
business this going in Reverse etc it
will work no matter what serious you've
got if I said you have a thousand times
it would still work if it was not going
up by ones but by twos or threes or
something like or eight into quarters or
something like that it would still work
it's two of the same symmetry so what I
would like you to try and prove is not
just proof but find for an AP 80 AP
which we all know fit like this right
this this defines every ap what is the
sum of the first n terms can you come up
with a nice neat formula that shows this
okay
I'll give you a few minutes to have a
play I will leave this on the board
because the DNA of the proof for this is
all contained within this one if you
think you have something called me over
and I'll let you know if you're on the
right track off you go
okay let me help you out so I've seen
some interesting approaches one of the
things that's really tricky whenever you
go from something general to something
sorry I've gotten the wrong direction
whenever you go from something specific
this is a specific ap to something
general you have to be careful because
you're not sure which parts of the
specific example a player as an instance
one of the things that I've had a look
around with some answers is people have
tried to say okay I'm adding up the
first n terms right well there's this
matching up between the first and the
last term you've noticed that haven't
you right first and last there's the
first and last and in fact every in
intervening pair is also equal to the
first plus the last okay now a lot of
people have noticed in this particular
sequence
the nth term for example the 100th turn
the nth term happens to be M did you
notice that right but that is something
of a coincidence to this specific AP for
example the example just gave to Eric if
I asked you to add up the first 100 odd
numbers not the first 100 counting
numbers right or the hundredths odd
number is not going to be a hundred
because a hundred after all is not an
odd number 100 is not even in the
secrets at all ok so something of a
coincidence here that the nth Namba
happens to the N this only works in this
case I have to go a little wider I have
to think a little more generally
thankful for us we have some various
general terms our PIAT these are true no
matter what ap or GPA you're looking at
ok so I'm going to use them as my basis
I've started this will I never working
here so I'm gonna use it if I've got s
of n then I know that double s of n is
just adding something back to itself
right so it's the same sequence or the
same series I should say but in reverse
order so it's going to look like this
dot dot it's going to end there but then
I add it to itself remember that and I
reverse the order okay now what this
helps us see is what's going on with the
pattern I've got the pairs I've got the
pairs right I know because of the way
I've lined up these pairs that you've
got T 1 plus T n at the start you've got
T 1 plus T and at the end and because of
the up-and-down nosov this ap every
single intervening pair is also going to
be T 1 plus T n so what I've got is T 1
plus T in and how many times do I have
that think back how many times it'll be
however many terms there are in the
series because that's how many pairs
I've lined up and in that case this case
it's n in fact in every case it's M but
of course what you come up with is not
the sum of the series this is not the
it's double the partial song so back
over here we divide it by two so I'm
gonna do the same thing okay now from
here we can land on a formula I'm one
line away from it sort of I just want to
point out see this and on to thing here
right it means something what it means
is how many pairs are there when I line
everything up another way that you might
see this visualized some textbook to do
this is they say you don't add as the
series to itself you actually just look
at the series as it is and just match up
the first and last and then match up
wrong line match up the second and the
second last and the third and the third
last so the question you need to ask
yourself is how many pairs how many
things can I pair up here now there's a
tiny little hole in that argument sort
of which is that you notice I've asked
you to add up the first 100 pairs right
100 numbers rather what if I asked you
to add up the first 101 then there will
be an odd one out weren't there there
will be a single term in the middle
right you've matched up everyone else
and that's the loan guy without a
dancing partner okay so what's
interesting is that this formula where
we've just landed on still works I'll
let you have a think about why that is
in a minute but for now I'm just going
to take this and I'm going to turn it
into the two formulas that you will find
on your reference sheet okay so here's
the first one they both have n on two on
them because they both rely on this
pairing up idea the first one simply
says well you know T 1 we have another
name for that right every other place
we've just called that guy hey so they
say let's call that a and then they say
well T n is the final term in this
partial sum it's the last term so
despite the fact that they've used a as
the first letter and Zed is the last
letter and actually call this guy L not
zero they use it L standing for last I
hate that cuz I'm like well if its first
at last say F plus L and if it's like
alphabet bingo a plus said but whatever
mathematicians use therefore something
else
that's the formula you will find first
time last time if you know where you
begin and where you end that's it okay
but then if you want to come over to an
even more general version of this I know
what L is because of this formula right
so I can substitute all of this stuff in
if I know the common difference rather
than where the ending point is I can use
that as well so again it starts with an
N on two they open a bracket and then
they say well you add your first term a
and then you add your n term which is a
lots of n minus one day like so you can
see in here it's kind of like ooh all
right if I sorry there's a plus there if
I collect like terms here you just have
a to a hanging out there and then here's
the number of differences you had on the
end of term so this is the second
version of the formula that you will
find on your reference to right at the
beginning of this topic I said there are
three ways to define progression right
do you remember what the three ways were
I've used a couple of them on the board
the first way to define a progression is
just say hey what are they what was the
name I gave that you just just list them
out just list them out okay so that was
one another way was you can use a
formula for the general term that's this
guy right there's one missing what was
the last one the Weidman the recursion
okay now I can use the partial sum to
form a recursion I can say alright I
have it written over here
doo-doo-doo-doo wherever I put it here
we go so I can say I've got enough space
here here's a recursive definition for
every progression that you can come up
with ap or GP or not an AP or a GP at
all and you can use the partial sum to
write a recursive definition you say the
sum of the first intercept term rather
is just the first term because you don't
have any other terms to add to it okay
but the sum of the first n terms is just
going to be the sum of the N minus 1
terms plus the last term the newest term
you can see why this is called a
recursive definition it refers to itself
in a number of different ways okay this
is handy this is handy because if I know
what the partial sums are right we've
started from the general terms and gone
to the partial sum but this recursive
definition helps us go on reverse order
right for example if I know what the sum
of say the first 100 terms is and I also
know what the first this of some of the
first 99 terms is right then that gives
me the general term do you see that like
I've just subtracted that from both
sides okay so this is a way this is our
mechanism for going from partial sums to
the general term as opposed to going in
the opposite direction